للوقوف عند اخر التطورات
الميدانيه مع الان مباشره من مدينه الفيف
مفت فرانس 24
اهلا ومرحبا بك معنا رائد كيف هو الوضع في
جبهه الشرق ولا سيامه في مدينه بخموت
ثلاث
جبهات اليوم ساخنه هنا تدور في اوكرانيا
لو بدانا من مدينه محمود حيث انتقل فريق
فرانكات قبل ايام الى هذه المدينه برفقه
عدد من الجنود المقاتلين قالوا لنا ان
الوضع في المدينه يتم قصف المدينه بشكل
مباشر ويتم ايضا قصف الطريق الرئيسيه من
قبل قوات الروسيه ولكن يقوم الجنود
الاوكرانيون بالاحتفاظ بمواقعهم لم يتم
تسجيل اي خسائر في مدينه محمود وبالمقابل
يقوم الجيش الروسي منذ همم
المقاتله مع الجيش الروسي هناك على مدينه
يقوم بالتوجه نحو مدينه بخموت ووضع مدينه
محمود تخ- تحت ضغط المدفعيه هذا من
المنطقه الشمال شرقيه من المنطقه الجنوبيه
هناك تقدم للجيش الروسي في محور قريه
كلاشيف كان ما يجعل هذه المدينه في فك
الكماشه دون الوصول الى وسط المدينه هم
يحاولون التفاف نحو الطريق الرئيسي الرابط
لمدينه محمود هي الجنود الاوكرانيون
يقولون لنا ان قواتهم ومواقعهم الدفاعيه
لم يخسروا منها اي شيء في مدينه بخموس هذا
فيما يخص مدينه ااه بخمد فيه الى الشمال
هناك محور صعب على القوات الروسيه وهو
يحمل اكرمنا الموجود الى شرق مدينه ازوم
حيث يحاول الجيش الاوكراني وسجل تقدم ضئيل
هناك نحو مدينه كريمينا بحيث يحاول
السيطره على طريق بسبن او ب-7 وهي الطريقه
حيويه مهمه للجيش او روسيا الذي ينقل عبر
هذه الطريق المساعدات العسكريه نحو
الدمباس عبر مدينه لسانس لذلك هناك محور
صعب على الاوكرانيين هو مدينه محمود في
الشرق ولكن هناك ايضا محور صعب على الجيش
الروسي في محيط مدينه كريماننا
طيب رائد روسيا تتحدث اليوم عن احراز تقدم
في اقليم سافوريتشيا ما هي اخر المعلومات
التي تصل من هذه المنطقه
نعم هناك تضارب في هذا المحور
تقول روسي انها سجل التقدما بحيث تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه انها ايضا سجل التقدم
هناك يحاول طرفان همم الحديث عن تقدم ولكن
منطقه ذا فويس كيد هي ما هو محور طويل جدا
يا من من تجاه مدينه محمود همم ينتشر فيه
الويه ميكانيكيه روسيه وهي ادويه من الجيش
النظامي المدرب فيه هذه المنطقه وخصوصا
هناك تغير في استراتيجيه الجيش الروسي منذ
تغيير القياده وهم يحاولون تسجيل وتقدم
والحديث عن تقدم ما يقول الجيش الاوكراني
ان هناك تسجيل لزياده في انشطه فعاله غير
فعاله ولا في هذه المنطقه للجيش الروسي
يتحدثون عن قوات اضافيه يتحدثون عن طيران
وقذف جوي اكثر يتحدثون عن طيارات بدون
تيار ولكن في هذه المنطقه هذه الادويه
الميكانيكيه روسيه سواء كان اللواء 125 او
129 او اللواء الميكانيكي للحارس المنفصل
136 وهو لواء روسي قاتل في في الدومباس
قاتل في حرب الشيشان هو ل- لواء بدروع
ودبابات ثقيله لذلك يعود هذا السبب
للمطالبه بشكل
الجيش الروسي الاوكراني يطالب اليوم بشكل
الحصول على دبابات يمكن ان توقف هذا
التقدم وخصوصا في محور ذا بويكا ولكن يبقى
السؤال هل تطالب اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات
لتستخدم للهجوم في ذا بويشا امل الدفاع في
فصل الربيع ضد القوات الروسيه
عن مدينه ليبيب والوضع في هذه المدينه حيث
انت
نعم وصلنا الى مدينه لفيف بالامس هنا
المدينه في هذا الجو البارد لا نسمع هنا
في محيط هذه المكان حيث الاوبرا على يساري
هنا لا نسمع الا اصوات
المولدات الكهربائيه التي تحاول تزويد
المدينه بالكهرباء هنا انقطاع مستمر
للتيار الكهربائي لشبكه الانترنت الشبكه
غير ثابته هناك تغير في في الكهرباء تنقطع
صباحا وتنقطع بعد الظهر ولكن يخرج الناس
حتى في هذا الجو البارد حيث اختفت الثلوج
التي سقطت على مدينه بيفتحدثنا مع بعض
الاشخاص هنا قالوا لنا الجو اقلبه من
الايام السابقه يقول لنا ربما لان همم
وهذا الاله ان يرحمنا في هذا الوقت وخصوصا
انه القطاع الكهربائي هنا يعني انقطاع
للمياه هو يعني ايضا انقطاع للتدفئه لذلك
مدينه لفيفا البعيده هنا من على التي توجد
على الحدود
الحدود الغربيه مع بولندا همم برغم من
بعدها عن الجبهه ولكنها تعرضت لاكثر مره
من قصر من قبل قوات الاوكرانيه لانها
تعتبر القوات الروسيه عفوا لان القوات
الروسيه تعتبر للذيب هي القاعده الخلفيه
لوصول المساعدات الاوروبيه والامريكيه الى
القوات لذلك يتم قصفها من من بين فتره الى
اخرى يتم قصف سكك الحديد التي تنقل
المساعدات العسكريه ولكن يتم ايضا قص هنا
المولدات الكهربائيه ويتم قصف جميع همم
المراكز الحيويه التي تغذي اوكرانيه
بالكهرباء والمياه شكرا لك رائد على كل
هذه التفاصيل كنت اذن معنى مباشره من
مدينه ليفيف اوكرانيا